hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over one of the most
important concepts in all of chess and
that is opposition and outflanking if
you understand these concepts your
in-game tactics strategy and overall win
rates will go up significantly so i'm
going to go over what these are
how it actually applies and then i'm
going to show you some examples from
actual games so you can see how you can
apply this to your own matches
this video is brought to you by
brilliant more from them later in the
video
so first thing we have to look at is
what is opposition now
one side is said to have opposition if
they're on the same file or row as their
opponent's king in this case both kings
are on the same file and white said to
have opposition if when they move
there's an odd number of squares between
the two kings in this example there's
five squares between the two kings so
white
has the opposition in this example all
that means is the black king is never
going to be able to get past
this white king
even if they tried to outflank which
we'll get to later in this video
now if we come back one move instead of
king to a2
if white played king to b2
now black
would have the opposition because they
can play
king 2 b
8
and now we can see that black moved and
now there's an odd number of squares
between the two kings so just that one
subtle move
from white can change who has the
opposition
so let's come back and break this down a
little bit more let's say that the white
king
wanted to make its way to one of these
three squares that's the game you could
play this by yourself against yourself
you could play with a buddy but your
goal is to try to get the king
to one of these three squares if you do
you successfully win the challenge black
is trying to keep you from this so this
all comes down to
can you find the opposition for your
side
so we look from white's standpoint let's
say that they try to choose the fastest
path and they say well i'm just going to
make a b line here we're going to go
king to b2 and we're going to just keep
going down this
diagonal right here but we already
talked about and said black now has
the opposition they can go king b8
well let's say white continues and they
play king c3 here
well from black's perspective really
they should play king to c7 the reason
they should play king to c7 is once you
have the opposition your opponent can
never take it back if you play correctly
but black needs to make sure that when
they move their king there's an odd
number of squares between the kings
and let's see why that's important let's
say
that white continues if they
move along the side and they play king
to d3
well black can just play king d7
maintain
they're still on the same file maintain
three squares an odd number between the
two
now if white doesn't play laterally here
with king to d3 what if they come up to
d4
well now
black can play king d6 remember every
time they move they want to maintain an
odd number of scores they could also
come back to d8 more of a trolling move
from their opponent it would do the
exact same thing but this is more
forceful because now there's only one
square in between which is an odd number
and now how does white continue remember
white's trying to get up to one of these
three squares up here the f8 g8 or h8
square but they can't come to e5 so they
can't come to the
diagonal that they want to they can't
come to d5 or c5 so they're going to be
forced to come to either one of these
squares e4 or c4 potentially but if they
code to either one of these you can see
black is just going to come e6 or if
they go to
c4 then they can go to c6 and yes white
could also just come back so if they
come e3 well now black can even push him
down even further and play king e5
remember they have to when they move
stay on the same file
and maintain an odd number of squares in
between because black has now the
opposition white can never regain that
if black plays correctly and because of
that that means that white is never able
to get past the black king and is never
going to be able to get to one of these
three squares and win this competition
okay so let's come back to our
competition and see how white if they
play correctly how they can win and then
we'll take a look at how you can apply
this to your own chess games to make
sure that you use opposition outflanking
to win more in the endgame so white's
trying to get to the f8 g8 or h8 squares
so the first thing when white moves is
they have to make sure they have the
opposition we already looked at king 2b2
is not going to win because now black
has the opposition with king to b8 there
are five squares between them white
really needs to play the move king a 2.
that's that first example we looked at
there's an odd number of squares between
them so white has the opposition
now let's say that black plays king b8
now we have to be careful white does not
want to play
king to b3 here
because black can play
king b7
and they would have the opposition
there's three squares between them so
that would be a mistake so if black
plays king to b8
because hey they're thinking i'm just
going to move my way over here
uh that's not going to work out for them
white needs to play king b2
now we'll continue down the board here
if they play c8 we play king c2
and continue all the way down at the
board now if they play king g8 we're
going to play king g2 but here's the
difference if they play king h8 we're
gonna come to king
f3
black is not able although we came up
one square black is not able to play
king f7 and get opposition okay so
that's not gonna work for black maybe
they play king g7 here remember white
had the opposition from the beginning
they can still maintain it so now we can
play king g3 still maintaining an odd
number of squares between the two kings
exactly what white needs to do
and now how does black continue okay
well maybe king 2 f7
now we can come to king to h4 and it
doesn't matter which side they go we're
now starting to outflank our opponent
now they may come back to
g6
but now we can play king g4
one we've kept them from ever getting
past us
but now we're using the opposition to
force our opponent to move and then
we're able to out flank our opponent and
get to our uh outcome of f8 g8 or h8 so
how did black continue from here maybe
they play king to h6 well now
we can outflank them and start moving on
the file we can go king f5
let me come back to g7 we're going to
come g5 to maintain the odd number of
squares in between our kings it doesn't
really matter where they go from here
they could come to f7 or h7
if they come to h7 we're not going to
come to h8 but we can come up here to f8
remember we're just trying to come to
any of these three squares
so if black plays king f7 we can just
play king h6 they could come to g8
but that's fine we come g6 we have the
opposition still there's one square in
between and now it does not matter where
black goes
we are going to be able to outflank them
and go around them so they play king to
f8 we can come up to king h7 and then
next move king h8 and if they play king
h8 well that's fine too we can come king
to f7 and we will reach our our
destination here with king to
f8
so that's an overview of the concept
quick word from our sponsor brilliant
and then we'll come back and look at
this in practice you can see how it
actually plays out in your own games
brilliant is the place to learn stem
hands on so it doesn't matter if you
prefer science technology engineering or
mathematics if you want to learn
interactively brilliant is the place
doesn't matter if you're like me and you
grew up doing math competitions this was
a research i wish i had growing up
because it's a really nice way to learn
math and then apply that and see if you
truly understand you could be someone
that's getting into computer science and
you want to learn how to code even at
the building blocks to make sure that
you have a good foundation or you could
just like puzzles you're watching these
chess videos and you want to see can i
actually do some of the logic puzzles
hopefully you can after watching the
chess videos but brilliant is the place
to go and also if you use my link in the
description below brilliant.org slash
the chesh website they are giving the
first 200 people 20 off an annual
premium subscription so definitely check
that out i think you guys will really
enjoy this website and now back to chess
let's take what we've learned and apply
it to a real world example king versus
king and pawn is
pretty common in chess and in this case
it's white's move and white plays
correctly they should win now the only
way for them to win is to promote this
pawn here on e8 to a rook and a queen
and then go on to checkmate their
opponent have another video if you're
curious how to checkmate with a king and
a king a king and a queen or a king and
a rook but right now we're just gonna go
over how they can ensure that they can
push forward now hopefully you remember
everything we talked about from an
opposition standpoint
but you have to start thinking about the
additional pieces that you have in play
because if you look at this and say okay
well it's white's move and white needs
to play king to d5
to get the opposition
this is true that is a true statement
they do have opposition on the black
king but any time they move their pawn
they're going to lose the opposition
so instead what white needs to do is
think about the fact that their pawn is
going to move
and how can they play accordingly well
the first thing they can do is play king
2e5
now that is going to give black the
opposition here
with
king e7 because there's one square an
odd number in between them but now white
has
pawn e4
that forces the black king to move and
now white is going to get the opposition
back let's say we have king d7
okay well you can see now we can
outflank black yes we can play uh king
d5 here and if uh they were to come back
to e5 we're essentially just waiting for
them to come to
to d7
and once they come to d7 it allows us
now to play
king f6 we're now starting to outflank
our opponent and there's no way for them
to stop it now if they play
king e6 or excuse me king e8
okay well now we need to go back to the
opposition as we talked about before
we're not really out flanking them
anymore we need to come back to center
with king e6 we have opposition because
we've moved and there's one square
between
the two kings on the same file
and now where do they go let's say they
play king d8 well now we can out flank
our opponents with king f7 here
and there's no way for them to stop the
pawn pushing forward
so they play
king d7 they can't come to any of these
e squares on e8 seven or six and so we
can start to push up our pawn here and
then eventually we're gonna promote our
pawn and they're not going to be able to
stop so king 2 or pawn to
e8 and promote to a queen so it's always
important to understand what opposition
is ultimately trying to outflank our
opponent but you also have to take into
consideration the additional material
you have in this case a pawn that we're
going to be moving as well so you take
the original concept and you start to
build on it and then you become a deadly
weapon that you will not lose games and
you also will find yourself in
opportunities where your opponent should
win but they don't quite understand you
do
and you can end up drawing a lot of the
games that you would have lost before so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video on
opposition and outflanking i think it's
just an incredible tool that you should
have
for
your chess in games
thank you again to our sponsor brilliant
reminder if you want 20 off an annual
premium subscription you can click on
the link below brilliant.org
the chess website thanks again for
watching i'll see you guys in the next
video